can I have it Hey all right fine then
whoa okay what the hell hi Hey oh it was
a mimic oh that's what's that one oh I
just wasted two goddamn shotgun shells
okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to uh
welcome back to pray we're off to a bad
start because I didn't even realize that
mimic why did I even think it was a box
that frickin moved
why didn't it process in my brain that
that could have possibly been a mimic
because I am dumb and that's why but I
think I got everything that I need from
over here so I'm just gonna make one
last glance around who what's up there
hello can I climb up you I think I can
and I've never been able to hi hello
science operator what are you doing up
there I'll be right with you in just a
second time on try this huh well yes
sure do that Lisbon yes that is me I'm
dr. Yoo ah that guy running for his life
was way better than this than I was well
let's see if I got a little bit of skill
here no
oh yeah that looks good
uh-huh hey whoa didn't expect that all
right hang on you go real close you can
real quote compassion your goddamn head
laughs oh no you're out cold
flap flap flap the opal and no you don't
ha okay forgot those guys handled pretty
good I'll take her and I'll take that
and I need it so many more shotgun
shells the painfully crafting them up
produces a lot of shotgun shells I don't
know how I all right yeah I'll be right
with you
hey hey yo freakin douche bag whoa where
you where you oh you got me good flap so
we got that escape pod key well that
seems important I don't even remember
needing an escape pod all right I'll be
with you in just one second I got the
airlock for second product or shoes
probably encounter those horrible
monstrosity is outside to my and kill me
oh so dead which was never a fun time
hello science operator you got a nice
voice can you come over here
Hey I'm calling you ty z-height operator
come back please Oh apparently I found
my way Labs be a new there's goodies in
there can I just scamper in here see I
didn't read with that note said not a
mimic uh-huh
one of these is going to be a lie no
that's for sure all right fine then not
a mimic
Londyn up there is a mimic though hey no
no no no no live live live level aha I
saw that okay look I for me just what
the hell I just thought oh hi hello
there I understand you give me a little
bit of oh yeah keep dancing for me baby
your dances you stand complete a mimic
matter Oh
mimic matter right uh-huh
shirt is flap flappity flap oh alright
god that guy wears out a mimic go oh
holy [ __ ] I glued him about Mendte meant
to get him meant to scan him but I
didn't get it she'll get plenty of other
opportunities whoever was in here was
paranoid well I mean for good reason if
everything around you could possibly be
a mimic then there's no reason not to be
paranoid it's the only thing that's
gonna keep you alive after a while and
there there are a lot on out there I'm
not gonna buy the collective mall cuz
that would just be a waste of my dime
and Donald [ __ ] hello Oh another
whiteboard whoa Oh what is that what is
all that I don't know but I want to take
this using mossbauer spectroscopy we
track hyperfine splitting of an isotope
invented in the target object in this
case a standard Transtar coffee mug
the creature seemed to have a weird
affinity for them if the medic actually
altered its atomic structures to
duplicate the target object then we
would expect the reading to be
consistent in the duplicated object when
the alteration occurred the reading was
prescient the frequency had changed the
new object was on a different time scale
than the original
well that's bizarre I don't know what
that means because that's beyond my own
idea hallucinogenic field the mimic
projects a field that causes observers
to think they see the object
transmutation oh this is hypotheses
mimic literally reconfigures these atoms
and molecules while somehow maintaining
its own subjective consciousness pocket
dimension mimic swaps place with the
objects in a parallel dimension but
stays connected via wormhole
well that seems like the least likely
considering how much energy that would
probably take to maintain a wormhole but
okay sure let's go with that hypothesis
what else they got here colorful now
what's with the yellow colors because
I've only seen blue electricity so far
and also what's with this weird hi know
almost angelic about some golden
filaments like a frozen light
- we've it out of thin air question is
why we have a lot of series but for
solid answers not yet okay cuz you're
with me Morgan not the way you are now
we used to be okay now we can tackle
this together like all times like all
times maybe before you trap me in a
constant loop of my own life my own
personal Groundhog Day introduce null
wave transmitter to test chamber to
suppress mimics abilities warning NWT
void test results Oh is there a mimic in
there whoa Oh alrighty then well we
tried that and that didn't seem to do
anything because I don't think there
were any mimics in there but I blew it
up real nice whoo hey oh let's try this
oh blur I guess it's too late didn't
that goof it up already alright fine men
I'm moving on that - alert I don't know
if I wanna lose I don't know why why
nice necessary a Typhon lure aka a
nightlight emits a psycho luminescent
signal that entices Typhon to move
forward the lure for a short period of
time combined with other weapons or
tactics to escape ambush or observe
Typhon from a safe distance it can be
thrown or affixed to a stationary object
well okay I guess the idea was that they
wanted to study these things more oh my
god oh it is beautiful just not hundred
percent sure why lap lap can i scan you
guys what is this it's like some sort of
Typhon planned but I guess you know if
they are even an organism if they even
have cells is a good question I guess
weird all right I'll take these sci-fi
boats and just be on my way
Oh
okay well maybe I shouldn't just you
know press random buttons are you doing
doing it's quickly screwed oh look at
you with your long swag legs alright
Rory I've loaded another light late
night light is requested up the psycho
luminescent this time to type on all to
follow the lure like an imprinted
dumpling oh and that's what it's doing
oh that was the lure okay well now I get
to kill that thing but still that's
pretty cool
whoo more neuroma thank you yes maybe I
could actually use them the nimac
technique I know I know it's said that
if I use too many of them I'm going to
lose myself but I have a funny feeling
I'm already lost to begin with weird
alright anyway yeah Eddie I don't think
I can go in there anyway I don't think
I'd want to hang on what's this hello
not a mimic yes this whiteboard is
definitely not a mimic good job you
figured out the mystery the Nappanee
black hello oh god damnit right through
my goddamn face freakin alcohol look
flap flap
all right get out of here where'd your
lo I see you're gonna try to get away
from me huh alright be better
this guy's got a glue gun sound like I
need more the glue guns but oh no he was
writing all the NADA mimic notes jeez I
dropped a couple of night lights to lure
the Phantom's away put sticky notes on
every goddamn thing I'm sure as a mimics
do good this costume oh I didn't mean to
do that I thought it was broken so I
didn't even know the point of hacking it
would be but here I go anywhere I
suppose get down there excuse you buddy
oh god oh god oh god oh god I've got a
guy I hacked it I don't know why I meant
to listen they listen to that again god
damn it I got give up the hell hey hey
none of that flap and flap okay let me
read this first I also realized I didn't
read the emails in the other room may
explain how mimicks arrived here and how
at least one survived in the vacuum
inside the Colet for so long they can
move to an adjacent dimensional bubble
where time passes much more slowly
shifting back with the appropriate
stimulus eg pray from the minutes
perspective at six million year journey
to our solar system in the form of an
iron meteor might only take a few
seconds these things are the ultimate
trapdoor spiders interesting let me read
these first though V a whole bunch of
numbers has shown signs for further
instability in the last 24 hours
subject demonstrated morbid curiosity
and small objects around him attempting
to place them in its mouth and consume
them initial diagnosis would seem to be
rapid onset Hika but there was no
evidence of this prior to exposure to
the telepath we're not ruling out
suicide attempts although the subject
isn't making an effort to hide it I'll
be performing an endo skeptic endoscopic
exam next shift to make sure nothing is
launching the esophagus or intestines
sorry 37 is still undersides
a suicide watch as requested the
prisoner hasn't given any sedatives to
keep the system clean for upcoming
surgery no food either only water he
doesn't do much except rock back and
forth staring at the same point on the
wall mumbling to himself in Russian
can't make out what he's saying he's
made no attempt to hurt himself from
what we've seen this volunteer doesn't
seem to be suicidal
he seems disoriented like he's sleep
drunk I've gotten I think we've gotten
just about all we're going to get after
37 by talking I want you to schedule
surgery within the next few days let's
get it out and into analysis as soon as
possible are you talking about his brain
you're gonna scoop out his brain is that
what I'm hearing here you're gonna
you're going to gladly scoop out his
brain because that's exactly what you
should be doing about that also guts is
what all guts is over there but there
was another terminal over here that had
emails I think and I get distracted they
did all right mimic theory after the
last six months here I'm going to pit
magic oh boy alright that's what they
were talking about with the different
versions of what could happen don't take
her three pilgrimage to the earth talk
autarky of domed arrived within my last
drop let me know if you'd like to
download the caves are all handcrafted
does Lizette ring any bells dr. Gus
Lanzetta what if I told you he worked
with us for a week one week the week
before the entire science staff had last
quarters neural mods removed
he left his badge in a locker I had IT
look up his account and who did them all
been deleted all that his credentials
who the hell was he well that's actually
fascinating because yeah somebody could
just waltz in if everybody had neuro
mods installed and then someone got
introduced and then a week later he
disappeared in everyone's neuro module
were removed then he would just be gone
right what's the point of a back-end
receiver there I don't even need it and
it's all just looping back and forth
alright what else do I need to listen to
this yeah
okay nevermind then I guess we're not
going to do that all right we're just
going to do this over I'm going to stand
right here listen to this [ __ ] okay
that's it all right then that's all
we're going to get out of that thank you
that was very helpful you're really
appreciated their way into this place or
they're just all locked off this seems
pretty locked off cognitive sciences I'm
gonna go over the other side see what we
can find over there man the mystery of
like what's going on because these guys
have been studying these mimics for a
long time now right they have to out
here I mean hi hi hey hey none of that
none of them which one are you which
object in here are you why are all these
broken why don't I have repair - okay I
know the people of the space station
blew up I forgot that we were in space
and probably an imminent danger of death
I vacuum man but they have Typhon organs
just lying around here it's no wonder
than any of them like got out in the
first place they just have everything
out in the open I mean if these things
are as infectious as I think they might
be which seems to be the case
considering that like these guys came in
on an asteroid just one of them and yet
they keep duplicating and when you shove
them in your eyeball it probably is
going to be bad and people are probably
gonna die from it we're a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well I'm gonna throw a grenade in there
don't know which one this is but there
we go
I don't think I was the one I wanted ah
how about that IRA whoa I got some of
them good I'll take that thank you very
much I don't think I have too many of
those but I know there's one more you
[ __ ] in here I don't know where you
went I want to find you all right fine
he's gonna be hiding like a little
blaster okay well that's not what I
wanted apparently real good because vis
ain't working right damn it where's my
god bin you know not that enough I
dropped a couple of nightlight there we
go phantoms away put sticky notes on
every goddamn thing I'm sure is a mimic
you good this safe inside the armory
this costume in Macbeth slipped in but
that's it I got everything still tight
what's our plan wait for rescue you know
if we make it alex is just going to pull
our mods you want to remember this [ __ ]
I think we could get out through the
guts work our way up to the Arboretum
okay say the word yeah something tells
me that wasn't too good of an idea
because I don't think it worked out for
them and also what's going on over there
like we must have encountered something
because I don't think that particular
video can end very well uh all righty
then but anyway there's still the skull
of dude in here somewhere for example
conducting a meta-analysis of over 2000
ganzfeld valve trials wherein
participants are subjected to mild
sensory deprivation in order to test for
telepathy reveals a hit rate of 39%
these results are statistically
significant meaning that the success
rate is above what could be explained by
chance alone there's no denying it
something spooky is going on ah
so people are getting all sorts of
spooked
here I need to find my way through here
Oh such a tan tacking these are going on
here that I don't need and I'm too much
of a pro anyway and look done record
time
and what if we get here the volunteer
Transtar sends us our irredeemable
sociopath sentenced to die for their
crimes we are neither judge nor jury we
only enable their already ordained
destruction to the benefit of all
humanity read the file on 13 if you need
assurance it's unlocked in the
extraction lab I managed to lock the my
morgue keycard in the morgue tell strip
thinks I'm an imbecile as it is have any
ideas nope I ain't got nothin L be you
because you're probably dead let me get
the rest of this find out where that
goddamn mimicking ha nope not that one
you hey with you ah I thought I would be
shooting you and it didn't work out that
way
alright where you going oh I see you oh
I see you okay no no no no I'm not blah
blah blah stay there
getting the rest of this other mimic
thank you that's what I needed mimic
matter number two we skip this guy
okay reload please remember faster today
your duns old where did you go you're
all the way over there oh it's another
phantom okay I don't need to go chase
after that guy just yet I need to keep
going forward where are my children
they still unlocked it's about
everything over here yeah come back to
that guy later hi-yah stop blocking hell
okay I'm going to flap you and I'm going
to flap you Wow and black what I think I
got it good enough man that was someone
who was that also this got anymore
anymore so I just used a key Lee when
the helo oh we're all good I need it I
mean it I'm gonna need it not today
yeah go come on kid go let's go p-- do
you need so much coupon yeah yeah there
we go
whoa that guy love stuff all right so we
got a medical officer over here but I
can definitely use because I'm dying
very currently yes please thank you heal
me oh it's because I need to learn are
you here for an appointment nice housing
special injuries nothing a portable
medical kit can handle yeah no no I get
to complete a patient questionnaire your
feedback will be invaluable all right
thank you
all right have a good day all right so I
think I got everything that I needed
over here so I need to find that it's
Cape Cod yeah it's gonna hurt me whoa
not today
oh yeah
you come from where are these these
freaking phantoms are coming out of the
wall stagger you back I'm gonna head you
boyer down oh whoa whoa execution-style
holy [ __ ] alrighty then I guess that's
cool
all right I'm gonna go in here and I'm
going to render all my [ __ ] into
broken pieces I don't think I need to go
outside into space just yet and I'm
gonna remember to do that up real good
like okay i'ma bop my boo-boos in there
and then we're just going there and slap
them into recyclables and see if I can
craft up another bit of Google sure
buddy boo boo boo boo boo okay what else
we got here we need to make I'm always
about more shotgun shells like that's
just wait it's just in Iran ah I just
saw in Iran whoa I can make a new room
on it
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah oh my god I need so much
more material
screw making bullets or anything like
that I need to make neuromas because now
I should be able to get something of
this now I know I shouldn't go too deep
into this but you know I'm just too
tempted
Geils up to 50 damage oh that sounds too
cool I want to do that one yeah let's do
it
oh hell yeah and then I'm gonna get the
mimic because that's just something cool
I don't know how to do that but I'm not
trying I'm turning into an alien
everybody I'm turning into a Frick frack
an alien who psionic aptitude many other
goodies than I need oh that's always
good I could get more health but I could
also get Salvage which allows me to get
more spare parts but do I really need
that many
Lula's oh those look pretty good I don't
look pretty good you know what might as
well if I'm gonna be used more of these
abilities I always want more psychic I'm
just I uh
oh god maybe it was a bad idea
don't know them do this to you ah oh do
you remember the first time you said it
was like you are outside yourself like
climate self-invented me waiting for you
to decide you move my chair without
touching it chills possibilities ah okay
as I believe now our mission is to live
all humanity in the same way okay yeah
sure that's probably a good idea sigh
targeting some powers are triggered
instantly by pressing Mouse to some
powers are targeted to stop time and
under side targeting mode press an old
mouse to use mouse to aim release mouse
to to execute power on the targeted
location or press f to cancel powers can
be equipped from the favorites wheel
there's probably like some purity way to
finish the game where you don't need any
of these mods to be able to do that well
what's the fun in that
holy [ __ ] why is that that's the girl I
don't know what I did
holy [ __ ] okay that's talking light
things on fire well that's handy dandy I
can't dude dandy dandy alright what I
need to do is I need to get over to
goods no no
Labs Ian have you so many labs hello
sorry
yes well oh I feel so much more alert
thank you very much did I just go in a
circle I feel like I just went in a
big-ass circle
well I don't all good good but that
seems like something can I climb out
there hole buddy Bobby okay what about
this
yeah that's probably good enough hello
oh oh oh okay all right there we go
where am I now why this where I was I'm
just wearing one word this doesn't help
me at all but I will use my will use
some super pair kits because why not
I've got them why not now that'll be
good for now I don't know if I need a
sale nice to see you
okay hi thank you you have a good day
now being all weird and whatnot I'm
gonna go down here I'm gonna see about
this escape pod key because guts didn't
seem to do nothing for me no wait wait I
wasn't even at guts yet that's right
okay I know where I'm going I think it
all right what do we got here uh-huh
yeah looks like you're gonna have more
time
probably allowing them to build all this
[ __ ] in the middle of your space station
is what killed all the people on it I'm
just gonna throw that out there and also
the fact that people seem to be turning
into all these Thai phones is bad just
began throwing that out there okay now I
know where I need to go I just went in
the big circle that it was already where
I was posed to be okay how good bullets
in the freaking toolbox everybody's
favorite pool than bullets
now we'll get here come on suppressor
man because live exams morgue oh that's
oh
ah it seems bad Oh goddamnit here the
signs is here we're in the middle of
something when they died access to the
gut is closed off during experiments
security protocol okay to finish what
they started why do I need to finish
what they started even 70s the first
research teams tried to communicate with
the time all has proved impossible their
cerebral structures are highly developed
and intentional but somehow
unapproachable
they have no speech of their own no
language they don't seem to even see us
not like way see ourselves I mean I'm
generalizing when I say us of course I'm
not a person not like you okay all right
then well way to be self-aware about
yourself in progress
local lockdown in a clock until
procedure terminate oh okay I wanna do
I'm gonna deploy the null wave oh don't
know why that startled me hey how are
you doing all right I'm gonna take this
from you we have a good day I'm good
Nana good day no I'm not open this up
and try to see what's in there because I
do not know open as me oh that's not
what I wanted to open oh maybe it is
maybe it is what I window
oh yeah or no well I got that all right
I don't know if it's gonna do anything
to me come on oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy okay let me see if blue affects it
but I have a funny feeling it okay let
me try to smack him that's a good idea
get that that's it oh god oh god oh boy
let me get this back up and pull it
glued that's not good so I can disable
my weapon somehow just a a comfortable
distance away BAM Matt back a hole that
seems to be able to do like a one-two
punch to him that seemed to do a one-two
punch for me as well that's okay got my
glue ready to goo
tap-tap there we go just being near that
thing supposedly does be damaged Oh baby
better this human features the - kill us
without hesitation but it's not because
the evil is because they can't do
otherwise
huh no what we discovered the greater of
hodgman's
all their wonderful abilities there's
one thing we can do that they can't
empathize with the suffering of another
living creature okay
oh hi what's gone there can i scan you
apparently well thank you for being
there I just repaired my suit like a
singers but maybe I would have needed it
for this one
alright good got that okay Kenny oh your
integrity is awfully good me like I knew
you would
Thank You robot buddy alright fine man
carry on so what is the Weaver the
Weaver seems to be the thing that
transforms like at least human anatomy
into something else
I mean even if its corpse that's super
weird it's able to turn corpses into
whatever the hell that was okay Lou
Danny whoa that's also useful combat
useful but relatively useful I'll take
it all right so I got both of these I
should be a bit more stealthy about my
life but you know may I keep blasting
forward at the speed of light into
everything I see let's get reload speed
up on that bad boy and let's get ammo
capacity up on that bad boy I need to
get rid of this - I wish I could
dismantle that right on cue oh is that
an ability the ability to dismantle
things right on cue oh if that is oh oh
oh that's a V oh that's handy if I
needed that but I don't think that
applies to absolutely everything
all right I think that's just for the
various things that would normally be
trying to keep oh oh okay alright I'll
go down here but I'm not gonna be happy
about it
I'm in the fork hey hey come on now I
know what you is I saw that
I'll never mind I guess I didn't see
anything I guess I'm just a all right
well we got mimics in here all right
tossing equip psychos go prior to
viewing but why why would you need a
psycho scope before you view something
why would you need that filter I mean
obviously they have some sort of psychic
influence there's a reason why that guy
was mind controlled but why they said
they had no language of their own and
yet somehow they're able to like
influence us they're able to pull well
that's the deterrent
party then good great I'm glad I did
that they're able to just do that I
don't know how that works also how do I
ooh how do I do that I wanna I wanna do
that I don't know how what what what oh
that's cool okay hi there hi that's
going BLAP oh wait come back wake where
are you going wait where you going come
on when it's kids limit you Oh No
you're jealous
more specimens ago and I thought I got
enough as it were
hi not salmon I mimics into a mimic
mimic a minimum in the maker I'm gonna
get you oh yeah they seem to die well
enough and know like by themselves so
they don't seem to be too incredibly
resilient I'm indisposed Demian Kelce
trip wants to discuss some urgent matter
the science operator lets itself in the
morgue by half-hour on the dot every day
shadow it and slip in remember how funny
I found Alvin Broyles movies up until I
had the second comment tutorial
combinatorics neuro mod installed now
they can't even elicit a chuckle I'm not
imagining this M I did I enjoy them
right Haley isn't happy about it ever
since she's scrutinized my every move
how much hot sauce I use where I put my
shoes before bed [ __ ] even my
handwriting you'd say you're still the
same person you were before your mods
with it would you I don't know I don't
know how in depth these mods are do they
actually rewire your brain only to the
way your brain is already wired or did
they rewire it to a template into what
another person already is hey there was
no need for that did you somehow blow
you all right man I don't know what the
hell just happened but something
happened more near real nazia City I'm
going to get Fayed I'm going to be dead
indeed unless I cannot to open this
[ __ ] so oh wait the science operator
every half an hour Lisa hi hi come on
you got to be goofy
oh no your dad okay but that means ooh
hey how's it going there how you doing
you don't look good but I'm gonna assume
you're all right whoo hey maybe I should
slap you ha oh come on
Brigance creamy screamer sit over there
why don't you take your wines and go
somewhere else
are you much more appreciated than where
I am hello thank you good thing I got
all this bio waste cuz I sure want to do
carry giant bags a fetid [ __ ] all over
the place that's my dream okay so
apparently the science operator goes
into that room but I have no idea when
that's gonna be and I'm not just going
to wait around for that even though oh
my god oh my god these poor people
there's so many dead bodies oh my god
there's so many dead bodies Oh alrighty
then alright cool cool cool cool alright
so anyway you see this again
okay so it said something about
shadowing a science operator but I don't
think there's a science operator in this
area I'm not on represent sure about
that but also I also just realized I
need to do this optional mission
somewhere in here in Alex's private
escape pod I need to find the key to his
escape pod in the neuro mod division
which means I would have to go back to
the lobby which I'm totally fine with
doing I just need to make sure that
going to Gus isn't going to absolutely
devastate my progress or not devastate
my progress but making sure that it
can't progress further anymore which
isn't necessarily a bad thing I'm not
saying it is I'm just saying I better be
thorough about this hey science operator
maybe I should shed and you want to you
want to go over there I'm gonna go into
the I want to go into the morgue the
morgue can I ride you oh you having a
good time there sorry don't buck me off
so I'm going to go look for this escape
pod
be right back when I get them where is
this weight this is weight this is back
to the beginning this back to the
beginning of the game where I first came
out of why would Alex use or at least
the key to his escape pod be over here
curious and curiouser I'll be back when
I find more answers what oh my god it's
been up here this whole time
sorry Morgan not sure how you managed
this but I can't love you have this key
card trust me you'd regret it what why
do I have disrupter stun gun hell yeah
your office isn't safe what does that
mean
I got a chipset but for what purpose I'm
so confused why did I come back here why
I wanted to follow up on my request to
view one of the volunteer abdication
contracts you're supposed to be off
today I had some free time so I thought
I already told you the cases are sealed
documents my hands are tied but if
there's some allowance for the
researchers oh my god the one pushing
the button I understand I really do
I think done is perfectly there are no
loss and you're tired it's affecting
your judgment now I'm all waiting it for
a while but not good look you might be
late for a meeting with Alex not too
late to flush it all out an airlock you
know okay are you having second thoughts
no way I'm it's just not the one
incriminated no have the answers for me
either way I'm trying not to think
possible
did you pick arrangement metals on board
it's gonna bring me food I don't need
the details
oh I put everything in a package to
label mementos the packages in my cabin
it's got to go every media outlet
imaginable Morgan it's that operator
with an earlier defective model or
something worse Alex the Tyson they're
all working against you drive some trust
the video you move we're worried the
army keys and destroy Talos watch you
might need this 374 640 late
in seven general interests oh yeah I did
why are you so curious about it hi okay
where'd you go
all right bye van you Skinner off into
the darkness the Taiping have already
demonstrated an ability to distort
technology including operator
programming storage the more you see of
Talos 1 the more you'll understand why
you made the decision to destroy
everything if it's not obvious already
yeah I understand if you feel uncertain
you goddamn right I'll do everything in
my power to help you and keep you safe
yeah sure you will okay storage Morgan
we need your arming key okay I'll
contact you again later
thanks January did you blow up December
earlier defective model I don't like the
Sanatana and I don't like January I
didn't see that there was something up
here let me try to go up here before I
continue back lower I
oh whoa whoa hey hey hey I'm up here now
anybody want a tussle with the muscle
the mark of all Zoltan coming at you
Shambo ski Sam lamb Oh amen
thank you I'm tired but there we go that
really take my time with that last hit
it was quite a wallop that I was gonna
lay down on you I just needed really
burying about it Oh what is up here this
is a day of exploration apparently
volunteering testing Oh something tells
me that volunteering testing isn't going
to be too fun someone tells me it's a
horrible place where people go to
the quote-unquote volunteers are these
the same people that can like convicted
to test then we're convicted to death
they're convicted to be death to be
death doubt they're going to die they
were convicted to be desc
fifty you know what I mean okay hello
why am i over here oh hi Manny Miki
slooshy all right yep your Spade is
sealed buddy I got a critical apparently
whoa where am I
what is this mate into white turn who's
doing chest
what nerd was doing chess over here oh
hello buddy these guys you guys aren't
able to see me very good we got a big
guy over there let's see about dealing
with them oh yeah see me yet hopefully
that means I can find some sort of
explosive canisters before I'm able to
tussle with him all right give me what
you got oh never mind I don't have
enough okay so I need to find a salvage
kid eventually but oh yes please and
we'll take that with great appreciation
so the only problem here is that all
these stupid mimic tumors are taking up
all my inventory space but maybe with
these neuromas I should be able to make
another inventory storage one yeah I can
okay so if I get that then I should be
okay yes all right now let me organize
this bad boy and let me pick up this
[ __ ] that I need on the easiest dude
all right so we got that let me pick up
this [ __ ] I don't check their shelves
enough that's just something that
doesn't register in my brain
that by always can I get the bio ace and
get the bio ace why can't I get the bio
is not that I want to put more [ __ ] in
sediment one ever take what I can get
we're not gonna pop that guy out because
I know I'm gonna be in soon
I'm almost got a glue dammit alright you
want to go mano-a-mano
how come on Oh any mono with you huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh no
you don't get close to me what could you
do what did you do what can you do you
can get dead that's what you can do take
some of value a little mastered all
right what do we got here oh these are
some of the volunteers for Weaver
testing to be we've woven into something
Horrible's bin' hello can you heal me
now that I really need it but any little
bit will help diagnosing initial
injuries nothing a portable medical kit
couldn't handle try relax good as new
you can fill out a service questionnaire
at the front desk all right whatever I'm
gonna heal anyway give him a food whoa
alright then why did we need to dramatic
music cues I think that was entirely
Linzer anything else I can get here no I
think I just went in a circle so there's
another path of a cure
Emile why why so many volunteers why so
many underhanded shady ways of going
about it I didn't do that
ah get blasted in the next century by
ouch
got more shotgun shells too so wasn't a
waste it was not a waste okay I'm not
going what does this lead to more horror
hell holes I'm gonna guess more horror
hell holes seems to be a majority here
thanks for the dorama Joshua again I'm
running into the situation with her so
many corpses endless corpses everywhere
white noise we've also we also talked
about that white noise makes it sound
like they're The Untouchables in the in
the Warhammer 40k universe you know what
I'm saying
big bang candy burns circuit or nothing
here nah no information whatever the
hell that is over there
I mean it's just a kind of like you know
cliche corporate espionage type [ __ ]
like shady shadow corporations testing
on the the myriad of people who are just
wait no I'm all the way back in our
indeed time to get over here oh I want
to go to there can I go over there who
can I go to there I thought that was the
thing that I was haven't I been there
before how do I get in there there's got
to be a way to get in there right oh I
want to go in there I think maybe around
nah that wouldn't leave me there I'll
get in there gotta be away I'll be right
back
oh that's right it goes through that
door I can't go there ha ha ha welcome
volunteers yay oh boy it's not a good
happy place happy place filled with
sunshine
oh hi okay I don't think I can move
these I don't think I can squeeze in
there
nah no hi yeah nope gotta get some hey
[ __ ] you
no no you know what I ain't gonna even
bother with you you just run off and be
stupid somewhere else
I'm gonna go risk death along here fine
back on track because apparently Alex
used keys in there but I did get the
code to it before January blue of
December and I think December was trying
to help me out and I don't know why
December and January we're different
people and I don't know why January is
trying to cover up for the death of
December by saying it was a defective
older-model I mean if there was anything
that painted January's a bit of a shady
object then that would definitely be the
one of them because I don't trust
you you're late I'm out of here baby I
am out of here and I don't think there's
gonna be the final frontier so I think I
should be okay also I have a jet pack
which is why I'm able to survive these
jumps now how the do be given your name
yeah wait where do you go
psychic products hell yeah let's go for
it shoot me okay so I'm wondering if I
have just enough flu oh whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] oh hell do you think
you are here you better back off of me
you better back off of me you don't know
what I'm gonna do to you you know what
I'm gonna do hey hey hey I mean hey I'm
sorry trying to get the mimics too many
mimics Randy thank you oh very nice
thank you very much for that I'm not
gonna get dressed a different [ __ ]
Trudy you know why I didn't just let
them all burn look last one yeah slap
hello
there's neural mods in there I want them
can you give them to me
oh yeah oh okay
where are my knitting cereal hi how are
you hi Homo sapiens
all right you seem like a hundred
percent human saamana trust you they're
about to be a choice here well you need
guns ammo
I sold in size pots go to that Armory
punch in the code you get me out of here
I'll let you have it
okay that seems like a fair trade Aaron
Aaron Ingram okay those other fellows
were russian i speak a little but as you
can tell I ain't from there uh-huh
as you might've guessed Amata
you know I used to be a reverend
training ward in place well I got locked
up uh-huh behold the wicked man
conceives evil is pregnant with mischief
and gives birth to live okay what are
you trying to prove here anybody you
know no it doesn't actually I don't know
okay
volunteer says subject criminal record
for y'all reverse proof reviewing
alright male human trafficking
kidnapping solicitation of a minor
distribution of controlled substances
fraudulent impersonation well he seems
like a bad guy please ranked mimic a rap
sheet huh yeah I sure AM I'm telling you
oh my mom is great that is a stack of
lies meant to make pushing that button
easier on you
what button okay fine listen I want to
be honest some of it probably is true
I've done some wrong in my days uh-uh
this ain't right now come on y'all got
to let me out of here okay well I don't
think I'm exactly an executioner here
something those kids I was just getting
them out of a bad spot can you just stop
talking your new criminals I didn't like
how chipper with their pile of rubles
they got the call something deep in the
government got me shipped off to the
gulag
can you just that's how I ended up here
can you just stop while you're ahead
okay I was debating letting you out all
right fine you know what I don't think I
can do extract mimic what does it even
mean does it mean extract mimic now god
dammit let me out
oh ho ho
methinks the mimics be going cray cray
in there whoa hey ha they're fighting
they wanting to get out real bad whoo
that is a lot of material on a moving
car that's so weird
I guess they get impatient after a while
all right you know what I'm going to
open this door not because I like you oh
because you're useful to me stab me in
the back at dari using the extraction
workstation complete the following steps
in the listed order while a volunteer
test subjects is present in the
distraction chamber extract mimic from
containment release mimic into material
extraction chamber when multiplication
process is complete extract exotic
material process material and collect
from dispenser tray immediately
transport remains to the morgue so I can
kill them for more exotic material but
what does that make me that makes me a
terrible shitty person so I'm going over
the door it doesn't make any sense there
you go you're free now I think I'm
talking about some human beasts friend
uh-huh
well hello what are you gonna do are you
gonna run oh where are you going hey
where are you going you said you'd get
me into the goddamn room gone now gone
now where's God where you going
Aaron you're the one person who showed
me any real kindness and you can believe
I won't forget it
well don't forget if I still want that
okay eight seven one four okay thank you
listen you running the other fellas
wearing a green jumpsuit watch your ass
are they in all decent human beings like
me hey down I've seen one of the other
volunteers come through here a big guy
bastard wouldn't let me out now I'm glad
he did
watched him bash some poor suckers head
in with a wrench
kept going on and on about black eggs
and whatnot real disturb alrighty then
so whatever you say Aaron you carry on
being a decent individual with a ha just
lay low for collar final a doubt for you
yeah okay you do whatever you think is
best I'm gonna go see what's going on in
this here thing or I guess that's not
where I go for it but I don't know how
you could have watched anyone oh here in
the armor you alrighty then eight seven
one four all right even and this is
where I just saw okay alright I'll take
what I can get let's do this I'll take
that and that that that Matt we got a
shotgun I'll take that while I got the
inventory space I can always go back and
dump this stuff break it down in
materials which is what I need these are
the materials that I need whoa
all right so I got a bunch of stuff I
want to run back to the I'm gonna run
back to the processing plant I'll be
right
I've got a spare one of these drums that
don't that all right that should be good
all right crank it crank yank it give me
some good stuff
give me more narrow bog baby chef do you
DVD ah that's exactly what I needed a
ton of mineral material because I think
that is the one thing oh yeah it is can
I get more they're all ours baby please
yes please yes please yes please oh yes
please thank you thank you thank you oh
thank you thank you very much okay so I
got that let me just carry on here huh
hello
I'll get it but when do you think will
gets that for each I mattered out there
as we speak what do you think happened
are you saying tell her my eyes on it
could be some micrometeoroids punched a
hole rare but it happens okay good
hopefully it's just that yeah hopefully
is there something you're not telling me
no of course not
it's just that storage room has
classified exotic materials we really
can't have it be inaccessible I
understand okay all right I want to get
in there too I just don't know what I'm
gonna be able to do that and get away
from the vision that's all for warping
in my mind and with this EU Christine
I'm sorry about that
but either way I'm all out of time for
this episode so thank you everybody so
much for watching don't know why
everything's going crazy here but uh is
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
Oh
[Music]